[Music]
okay everybody i am
so excited today because i am joined by
leslie anne brandt herself aka maize
from
lucifer how are you doing today leslie
ann
i am great thank you very much
oh yeah so i was so excited to talk to
you having that lucifer
5b is out today can you just getting us
prepared for this as lucifer fans kind
of get us into where
maze's head is currently at where how
she's able to really make this big
choice of now like siding with michael
well i think a lot of that comes from
just her
um you know feeling like
she is uh
tired of her being taken advantage of
or her that relationship i would say
those two
um you know he kept a very big secret
from her
one that obviously carries a very deep
and painful wound
and so um
you know she reacts the way
maize does which is from a place of her
and
that old saying of her people hurt
people
um is true i think you know for both of
them
so speaking of hurt people hurt people
and stuff that's hurt maize
i love how we got more into her
character and about her mom abandonment
issues
um do you think this trauma where amaze
is at now do you think it still dictates
a lot of her day-to-day decisions
or is it something she's starting to
like heal from and accept it in a way
um i think that the the
the remnants of that wound is is even
unbeknownst to her has sort of dictated
a large
part of how she kind of relates uh
to people um i think being abandoned as
a child
uh puts her roles up really high and
so she comes into this series not really
trusting humans thinking that sort of
emotion human emotions like love and
kindness is all kind of [ __ ] you
know because that's her experience right
um and and i i would dare to say her
first
experience of like true love um
uh is is probably in a sort of weird way
with lucifer in terms of that friendship
but then
but then she really starts to find it
with this family she
creates here on earth um and realizing
that
um imperfection is can be beautiful as
well
you know because she is certainly an
imperfect
character as are her human friends they
do things to piss her off
you know and as is her friend lucifer
who does things to piss her off but like
working through
um struggle is as uncomfortable as it
feels
if you really really want that person in
your life that's something you have to
do
yeah and that's such a great scope into
maze's character you just gave us
and now i'm wondering how much of leslie
anne
do you find in the character of maze
that you can relate to
oh my gosh so much i mean when people go
uh who is the person that's most like
the character it's
typically nine times out of ten it's me
um
i love that yeah i mean i
i would say you know um
i would say it's probably the character
i mostly like that i played
in the sense that you know she is
an immigrant from hell i'm an immigrant
from south africa by new zealand
um she you know
comes from a completely different
culture and understanding of how things
work so do i
she struggles to you know figure out
her new home so did i when i moved to
new zealand and then
you know to america she
is very loyal and protective of the
people she cares about that is
me she is outspoken that is me
um she uh
but and and like her actually sometimes
that strength
is taken for granted you know people
think that there is no santa cord that
is
mushy and kind of feels what we feel
so um so that is
where we are very similar um i think
i've
learned a lot from her as liz lee anne
um
you know that it's okay to pick the
fights you want to fight
you don't have to fight for everyone
because not everyone is deserving
um and and it's okay to sometimes
take pose um and take a step back and
and figure out where you want to direct
your energy
um to and and again
if that situation is worthy because i do
feel like sometimes lucifer has to fall
on his face
you know and may should let him yeah
yeah he might learn something you know i
like that
yeah um but you mentioned
fighting and i i wonder you have this
great video you just shared with your
you're fighting these 10 guys in this
sequence that we're going to see
how difficult is this the hardest part
of this role is learning these intense
fight sequences
no it's the that's the least hardest
part of the role
i think the hardest part of the role is
walking this fine balance of exploring
her humanity and all these relationships
but we must never forget that she's a
demon so there always has to be an
element of danger
um and it's a fine balance you know
because you can either play her just one
note as being
a badass or you can every single scene
it's sort of
you know tears and crying and but that
has to
come from a real place of truth so it's
finding the balance with that but the
physical stuff i love it i mean it's
kind of
like it's like learning a dance for me
you know like sure you know i think most
people know that i throw myself into the
physical aspects of playing my
maze sort of wholeheartedly um
and i uh i think it's a big part of
i love to see female characters who are
as physical as maze where you really
believe like they could snap your neck i
think when you physically don't look
like that
like you could do it it makes it really
hard um
or if or if you can see who is doing the
stunt versus the actor like i like to do
as much as i can
so that people never know when it's me
or a stunt double
you know yeah and i mean it comes off
that way you absolutely kill it and you
really do hit also that fine line you're
talking about humanity and demon
and that's why i think it's so great
that you bring this to the role and
i think what people also love about you
playing maze is that
you do that thing where you show passion
for the show especially on social media
and i really
appreciate and love even sharing these
pictures of these awesome
costumes for maze is that
more of a collaborative effort than
people realize between actor and costume
designer because like
i think some people just imagine costume
designer shows what to set gives you
your outfit you put it on like can you
explain how that kind of process works
for you on the show
um it really depends on the actor as to
how involved they want to be
um you know i can't speak for anyone
other than myself
i certainly do think that how she
presents herself
is a big part of how she is ingested by
the audience
um you know and so i wanted her right
from the beginning
to turn heads when she walked in even if
she didn't have
you know lines necessarily i want her i
wanted her presence
to be felt because i needed her presence
to be
unique and intimidating at the same time
which played into the danger of the
character you know
um and i think that there's real
storytelling that can be told
through wardrobe and hair and makeup as
well i learned that actually on my very
first
big u.s series spartacus where as
characters got um
more darker their wardrobe got darker
you know like
uh so for maze when she's a bounty
hunter there's some more practical
like denim and jackets and when she was
in the bar it looks there was a lot more
corsets
and kind of other worldly older
like looking items that could have been
brought with her from hell
um but yeah i i i collaborate very
closely with avatar our
costume designer and with the hair and
makeup department
i love i love to hear that and that's
really cool so you really do
everything like 100 which is awesome and
i also you mentioned about being on a
big series
like spartacus and then you go into big
series like lucifer but did you notice
any difference
especially just for yourself and
following and people and fans when it
went over to netflix did you
kind of sense spike up yeah netflix i
think is in 167 countries now
so we immediately gained
this in crazy audience but then also you
know
lockdown happened and people had time to
discover our show
and i think we got an entire new wave of
eyeballs on
the show um because of the covid
lockdowns um so
that was i guess the silver lining you
know um
in this really crazy year and i think
the value of entertainment
really improved you know that we get to
take you away from escape what was
happening and
and we do it in like a show that's sort
of fun
it doesn't take itself too seriously but
when it is serious those
those um themes are really deep and
meaningful
um but yeah
yeah no that that's great and that's so
true and i think like you said it's
something that can help people escape
and this is a kind of perfect show
for that now switching gears a bit you
mentioned in your instagram bio that
you're living with a confused accent
is it still as confusing today do you
switch between different accents during
the day where are we right now
okay yeah this one is when i say
confused
it's like what i've learned to do as an
immigrant who you know my south african
accent is very thick
and it feels weird to sound like this
when i'm in south africa and it just
innately like changes
so that i'm with my home sort of
people my town my my my country but um
a lot of americans struggled in the
beginning or
they confused where i'm from and every
now and then it's like it sounds kiwi
with
a little american and then a lot of
south african
so i don't know it's this like weird
hybrid of my life
essentially um it makes sense
oh yeah it's cool it's part of you it's
awesome and
well i love too i was scrolling down
your twitter and there's a picture you
share
if you just explain to me you mentioned
it as like a daft punk type helmet you
were wearing in the video on twitter
what is that it's called the air micro
and it's this amazing like i went to
travel with it because i was like i am
not going to sit on a [ __ ] plane
with for 14 hours
lost up and so it has this battery lost
for 12 hours and you can recharge it
and it has a hippo filter but it's like
literally goes over it has a fan in
there with a hippo filter
oh that's amazing yeah so you get to
one people get to see your face so you
know you're not
like hey i'm really smiling with my eyes
you know um
and but then the the downside is that
it's not a downside but when you're
traveling or rushing to a gate and
you're like can
you know people recognize you um but
that's the thing about the mosque so
that
is that it does help conceal it a little
bit so that you get to kind of maneuver
you know in public spaces because i'm
i'm still like hey covet is real so
yeah so i'm not being rude
there's no chance though someone would
run into in a grocery store with that
helmet is this just for going on planes
hell no i'm vaccinated so listen
the science goes both ways you know
you're right you're right you get
vaccinated
we can enter the world a little bit
easier but
no i i was really grateful and they sent
it to me so thank you
air micro for micro climate yes i love
it
um so leslie ann they announced that
season six
will be the final season of lucifer
coming up yeah
do you think it's the right time or do
you think there should be more how do
you feel about that
i think it's the right time i think you
know
um i we were never supposed to get a
season six season five is gonna be
it and it's just the show that could
it's like
cancelled twice you know over five twice
it's
kind of amazing but i think really we
would
um you know i
i think our writers had squeezed every
bit of story they possibly could
for that was good you know
um so that our show could go out on a
high
and that we could pay homage to
these characters um and respect their
individual journeys without it being
you know cheesy we've all seen shows
that end in a not great way
um i really hope that the fans i think
they will be really happy with where we
do in the series
and um and especially for magic king's
character she gets what she
ultimately um
what she ultimately needs not
necessarily what she wants
but ultimately what she needs um
and um and that is
that made me very happy to be able to
feel like i buttoned you know
that up that being said i always do feel
like
i i mean people i've talked about is
spinoff and i'm like yeah there's a lot
of nazi keen story
to to tell um
but i think not in our world that we
created i think we sort of like
said goodbye to her in that world yeah
no yeah but look both those things you
said are going to make a lot of people
happy as well that's exciting to hear
that she gets a nice button
and then you make a really good point
about having it a separate world but
again thank you so much for joining me
leslie ann i really appreciate it
everybody check out lucifer5b it's out
today on netflix go watch it
enjoy it on your memorial day weekend
also follow leslie anne
on twitter and instagram at leslie and
brandt she's a great social media
uh account that she's got going is there
anything else like to plug before i let
you go leslie
i know just enjoy the show you know um
i don't know bunch it all at once or let
it slow drip
whatever floats your boat
i love it thank you so much leslie anne
and i hope to talk to you in the future
one day
thank you so much nice to meet you